as a president waging a war of words
over terrorism us-backed ear rocky
forces are on the front lines of that
war
troops in Mosul are closing in on the
last neighborhood still under Isis
control the fighters are preparing for
the final battle to retake control of
the city Isis militants captured Mosul
in 2014
Charlie d'Agata is in western mogul only
about 300 feet from Isis positions on
the edge of the old city good morning
this narrow street is now the front line
in the fight against Isis Iraqi forces
have been closing in on three sides and
on the other side of this Isis
stronghold is the river Isis fighters
have only two choices they can surrender
or they can fight to the death because
Escape is not a possibility we've seen
for ourselves with this fight now
entails it's guerilla warfare as we were
led through holes that had been cut out
by Isis as they went from building to
building until we reached a high point
where rocky forces were trying to take
aim at sniper fire soon they would see
the muzzle flare and then they opened up
with their machine guns and trying to
take Isis out it was explained that Isis
tried to provide cover as Isis fighters
advance and this is what it's come to a
standoff here as they're trading
gunfire back and forth even along this
alleyway
they've strong blankets up in order to
stay out of the view of Isis snipers
Iraqi forces have made significant gains
in the past few days but now the fight
is for the old city and nobody here is
willing to predict how long that will
take for CBS this morning Charlie
d'Agata Mosul Iraq